Bună și bine ai revenit la seria de cursuri Variational Quantum Eigensolver.
Mă numesc Victoria Lipinska și în acest video vom explora cum să reprezentăm
o problemă VQE dată într-un mod pe care calculatorul cuantic îl înțelege.
De obicei, o problemă de chimie cuantică este exprimată în termeni de energii
ale sistemului.
Ne referim la operatorul care descrie aceste energii ca Hamiltonian.
Mai întâi, trebuie să-l cuantizăm.
Adică să-l exprimăm în limbajul chimiei cuantice,
care se numește formal a doua cuantizare.
Dacă Hamiltonianul descrie interacțiuni fermionice, de exemplu,
energia electronilor în orbitali de spin, ne referim la asta
ca Hamiltonian fermionic, și acesta va fi punctul nostru de plecare azi.
Qubiții, însă, au propriul lor limbaj.
Operatorii din lumea qubit sunt descriși de operatorii Pauli.
Așadar, scopul nostru aici este să exprimăm operatorii fermionici
în termeni de operatori qubit.
Există o corespondență simplă unu-la-unu între
stările zero și unu pentru fermioni și qubiți.
Deci maparea dintre stări este și ea directă.
Totuși, maparea operatorilor este puțin mai complexă.
Hamiltonienele fermionice sunt exprimate cu operatori de creație și
anihilare.
Deci sarcina noastră este să facem mai ușor pentru un calculator cuantic să înțeleagă
Hamiltonianul.
Vom folosi instrumente matematice pentru a mapa un Hamiltonian fermionic
într-un Hamiltonian qubit cu gate-uri.
Cu alte cuvinte, vom face traducerea între
limbajul chimiei cuantice și limbajul calculului cuantic.
Imaginează-ți două lanțuri, unul cu fermioni,
deci limbajul chimiei cuantice.
Și unul cu qubiți, deci limbajul calculului cuantic.
La prima vedere, maparea pare simplă, nu-i așa?
În ambele cazuri, vedem sisteme cu două niveluri.
Pentru fermioni, avem fie un fermion în stare
fie niciun fermion.
Iar pentru qubiți, avem fie starea 0, fie starea 1.
Totuși, e mai nuanțat decât atât.
Diferența dintre un lanț de qubiți și un lanț de fermioni
este ceva foarte fundamental în fizică: ceea ce numim simetrie de schimb.
Doi fermioni nu pot ocupa niciodată aceeași stare.
Totuși, pentru un lanț de qubiți, lucrurile stau complet diferit.
Doi qubiți pot fi amândoi în aceeași stare,
deoarece un qubit nu este un fermion.
Trebuie acum să găsim o modalitate de a face traducerea între cele două lanțuri.
Încă din 1928, doi cercetători, Jordan și Wigner,
au arătat că operatorii fermionici pentru întregul lanț
pot fi reprezentați exact în termeni de operatori qubit.
Aceasta este cea mai directă mapare pentru un calculator cuantic.
De exemplu, se poate folosi asta pentru a mapa ocuparea
unui orbital pe spinul unui singur qubit.
Practic, această mapare pentru un Hamiltonian duce la o sumă ponderată de operatori Pauli.
Acesta este un fapt foarte important, pe care aș vrea să-l reții,
și vom reveni la asta în modulul următor unde vom vorbi
despre cum sunt executate circuit-urile variaționale pe calculatorul cuantic.
Maparea de mai sus înseamnă că dacă am avea, de exemplu,
14 operatori fermionici, vom mapa problema pe 14 qubiți.
Din fericire, există metode inteligente pentru a reduce numărul de qubiți
și a folosi mai puține resurse cuantice pentru a obține o performanță mai bună de la un calculator cuantic.
De obicei, într-un sistem molecular, vom cunoaște
unele simetrii fizice ale Hamiltonianului,
de exemplu, numărul total de electroni este fix.
Această informație poate fi folosită pentru a reduce dimensiunea problemei
fără a pierde nicio informație relevantă.
Numim această tehnică reducerea spațiului activ.
Aceasta permite reducerea numărului de resurse, adică a numărului de qubiți,
înainte de maparea qubit precum transformarea Jordan-Wigner.
Acest pas calculează un Hamiltonian efectiv
și ne permite să folosim mai puțini qubiți ca rezultat.
Pentru exemplul nostru cu 14 orbitali,
această tehnică reduce numărul de qubiți la doar șase.
Putem merge acum și mai departe cu aceste reduceri.
Putem folosi mapări diferite,
care sunt puțin mai elaborate decât Jordan-Wigner.
Cel mai comun exemplu este maparea de paritate.
Maparea de paritate nu mapează ocuparea orbitalilor pe qubiți,
ci paritatea orbitalilor pe qubiți individuali.
Nu vom intra în detaliile matematice aici,
dar ce e important de știut este că această mapare conține
redundanțe suplimentare care pot fi folosite pentru a elimina încă doi qubiți.
Prin urmare, exemplul nostru cu 14 orbitali se reduce de la 14 qubiți
la 6 qubiți cu reducerea spațiului activ și apoi la 4 qubiți
cu reducerea de doi qubiți din maparea de paritate.
Să menționăm pe scurt încă o transformare.
O altă mapare frecvent folosită între reprezentarea fermionică
și cea qubit este transformarea Bravyi-Kitaev.
Transformarea Bravyi-Kitaev folosește qubiți pentru a codifica informațiile
atât despre numărul de ocupare, cât și despre paritatea stării cuantice.
Transformarea Bravyi-Kitaev combină informațiile despre numărul de ocupare și paritate
pentru o bază de orbitali moleculari de dimensiune N,
sunt folosiți din nou N qubiți.
Totuși, informația stocată în fiecare qubit
variază acum în funcție de care qubit este.
Adică atunci când indexul qubit-ului este par,
acesta stochează numărul de ocupare al orbitalului corespunzător
ca în maparea Jordan-Wigner.
Când indexul qubit-ului este impar, qubit-ul stochează paritatea unui anumit
set de numere de ocupare. Transformarea Bravyi-Kitaev este cea mai eficientă
când numărul de qubiți se apropie de o putere a lui doi.
Maparea Bravyi-Kitaev combină avantajele din Jordan-Wigner
și din transformările de paritate.
Reduce numărul de qubiți asupra cărora acționează fiecare termen al Hamiltonianului,
E important pentru simularea cuantică deoarece termenii
care acționează pe un număr mare de qubiți în Hamiltonian
necesită circuit-uri mai lungi pentru simularea lor.
Asta înseamnă că adâncimea circuit-ului
este redusă cu transformarea Bravyi-Kitaev și, în general,
putem obține rezultate mai bune cu hardware-ul.
Acesta este un avantaj față de transformarea Jordan-Wigner
care duce la un Hamiltonian qubit de ordinul N.
Deci, în acest video am explorat metode de mapare
a unui Hamiltonian fermionic pe un Hamiltonian qubit.
În următorul vom vedea cum să selectăm cel mai bine starea
și o formă variațională sau un circuit.
Ne vedem acolo.